okay we're
opening the executive session
before we start that
we have
replacing
replacing mary griffin
replacing representative amanda gorg
is representing matt rohn
where's
okay
and replacing
representative southwark
thank you all for
agreeing to come in and
i make a motion on uh
house bill uh a uh zoom study on house
bill 15.
i make a motion of interim study on
house bill 1565
second
the motion
of interim study
made by representative romney second by
representative almi
i want to speak to you in motion uh yes
well first of all
i'd like to thank representative
aaron for bringing this bill forward
um but you know the more we melt we
think about this that there's a this is
a major change we're talking about doing
here
in changing the percentages that go to
the this has to do with the opioid
settlement money
and that that part of money's growing
every week in terms of the settlements
that are coming in and
i for one wanted actually to see more
but after after further discussion with
rep
a g buffet
it's clear that there was a lot that
went on behind the scenes to establish
the allocations the way they were
and i think we need to let those settle
in
before we start changing the
distribution formulas
what we just decided uh i i think i
think the best thing for us to do so to
keep this alive
i have no problem changing this down the
road
uh
to to a new formula or at least to
recommend a new formula
but for now let's let this get off the
ground
um it's not going to be until march the
department of health and human services
rules are going to be heard on march
15th
and then shortly hopefully shortly
thereafter they'll be going to jail car
so that we could start spending some of
that first 2.7 million at opioid money
but since then we've had another
settlement for another 115 million then
we had another settlement for another 46
million and there's others that are
coming
so uh with that we i think it'd be
prudent uh to keep this alive by via
interim study
uh and not not i think we really do need
more conversation on this bill before we
start tampering with the formula so
i hope everybody joins me in an interim
study thank you
saying none i'm not going to ask the
clerk to call the vote
if you're in favor in terms of study
you will say
yes and if you're opposed no
thank you mr chair um and before we
begin roll call
a lot of people are watching this at
home on youtube and sometimes it's hard
to hear what you're saying so whatever
you have to say whether it's in roll
call or anything else say it loud say it
proud into the microphone thank you
the bill is hb 1565 the motion is
interim study we'll begin the roll call
vote with representative abrami yes
representative true
yes
representative orry
representative doucette
yes
representative lang is not in the house
metaphorically
the clerk representative berstein votes
yes
representative genigen yes
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative wallace
yes
representative aaron yes
yes representative ames yes
representative ebal
yes
representative malloy yes
not
here representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo yes
representative laughman
yes representative wilhelm yes
representative hacken phillips yes
representative murphy yes chairman major
yes
the vote been 21 to nothing the motion
of interim study passes
without objection to go on
consent
i see no objection so it'll appear on
representative romney
so everybody knows
the senate has five of our bills or four
of our bills being
heard right now
representative lang is over there and
representative schaumburger is over
there we knew this vote was going to be
unanimous that's why we voted without
them
i have to go over it about 20 after and
then i have to go up i have to go over
like 22.
so there may be some bumps in this uh
process here
um because what can i say it was
supposed to be nine o'clock
and then they change their schedule to
10 o'clock and so we've got conflicts
some of us have to go defend our bells
okay
we're going to
go out of executive session
and go into a work session on house bill
an act relative to taxation of income of
new hampshire residents
when working remotely for an out of
state employer
on 1097
1037h yes that is the only amendment
that's before us and it was distributed
last evening so uh okay that's uh
representative spillsbury it's your
amendment we want to
explain your amendment
thank you mr chairman
so i believe
in the discussion uh during several work
sessions it was generally agreed that
the state of new hampshire needs to do
something
to counter the
actions of the state of massachusetts
during the pandemic
asserting
the power
to assess real estate taxes and i mean
excuse me income taxes and withholdings
on new hampshire residents
who previously commuted to work
in
massachusetts but were then working from
home despite that all the work was being
done within the state of new hampshire
the original bill as drafted
takes the stance
that we are going to assert that no
other state has the power to do this
we don't directly have the ability to
define the power of another state or to
control it so we decided that we should
reframe this so that we can take some
action that's meaningful
with the idea
that if our attorney general again has
to litigate
we want to give them all the armament
they need
so that they can cite to a direct
position of the state
and lay the foundation for a strong
claim of standing
and in effect it puts us in a position
to say
while we can't control massachusetts we
can defend
an infringement on our sovereignty
so the bill has three parts
the working part is f
78f1 purpose
this makes the assertion
that
we john genegion and i
have worked out with sam garland
assistant attorney general and king wong
at the dra
and we're very pleased with it it says
in order to promote the health of its
economy and the welfare of its citizens
by preserving an environment in which
labor is not unduly penalized it is
declared to be the sovereign interest of
the state of new hampshire that the
income earned and received by residents
of the state of new hampshire for
services entirely performed within the
state of new hampshire
may not be subject to taxation as earned
income in any other state
the f2 and the f3
are qualifiers that are just designed by
the dra
to ensure that nobody can make an
interpretation
that business taxes uh
cannot take account of all business
activity wherever it's been done across
the for the 50 states or worldwide in
fact
so um
this is just
qualify our language to make sure that
i
wouldn't ordinarily read a blurb but
this is fairly technical stuff and so if
you'll indulge me i think you probably
would benefit from just getting a
this bill addresses an issue that arose
during the covet 19 pandemic when the
commonwealth of massachusetts required
that certain new hampshire residents
who customarily commuted to work and
employer sites within massachusetts but
who instead were working exclusively
from home in new hampshire
should continue to be subject to
massachusetts personal income tax and
withholding requirements
governor sununu immediately lodged
objection to this assertion of taxation
power across state lines
but massachusetts did not back off
subsequently new hampshire through its
attorney general filed suit before the
united states supreme court
invoking the court's
original jurisdiction quote unquote
under the u.s constitution to resolve
legal disputes arising directly between
two states
the court decided to not take the case
despite assertions that it was required
to do so
dismissing the complaint without
explanation as is common
one can speculate as to why the justice
is elected not to take up the case
knowing that this is a power that they
are reluctant to invoke
and knowing that they often seek to
avoid further burdening their calendar
when they do not believe a particular
controversy demands resolution by them
at that juncture
one possibility is that they did not
detect that the state of new hampshire
had a sovereign interest to protect
independent of the claims of the
individually aggrieved taxpayer who
might conceivably be asked to litigate
in his own right
thus drawing into question the issue of
standing on the part of the state
alternatively they may have conjectured
that the dispute was temporary
likely to disappear soon as the
emergency receded
indeed more recently in october 2022
massachusetts led its emergency order in
this regard lapse as the pandemic was
lessening in urgency thus rendering the
pending dispute moot
even so the committee took up the bill
with an eye on preventing a recurrence
as originally drafted hb 1097 asserted
that quote no state has the power to tax
value earned outside of its borders
close quote but it created no viable
means of enforcing such an admonishment
directly
against any other offending state
and it potentially created ambiguities
over the term quote value earned close
quote
the committee believes that hb
1097 addresses a very important issue
that was offensive to new hampshire's
independent sovereignty and that this
issue must still be addressed
preemptively lest it arise again without
recourse
but the bill needs to be reframed in
concert with the attorney general the
department of revenue services the
committee's amendment seeks to address
that weakness by re-aiming the bill
towards firmly and unequivocally
unequivocally
establishing an explicit claim of policy
and sovereign interest that will put
other states on notice and clearly lay
the foundation for successful litigation
well thank you representative
spillsberry for your hard work on this
and uh thanks as well to the agencies
for
working on this with
you and whoever else worked on it
uh it's a complicated matter i
here's my
question however
uh the concern that i think
lies behind in
adding the two additional
parts about business taxes
is that in fact
with our business tax and particularly
with the adoption of the single sales
factor
new hampshire
is and will be
taxing income
earned and received by residents of
who are part of
a business enterprise whether it's a
partnership
a sales proprietor
or a corporation that is selling into
new hampshire
where the services are
that are taxed are entirely performed
and we want to continue taxing
that
uh those sales that income is produced
by those sales so we didn't i believe
these sections are in there
to make clear that we want to keep
taxing them well so do other states want
to keep taxing us
as we sell our businesses sell
into those other states
so it seems to me you're setting up a
double standard
and a situation that's uh
very unlikely
uh and i haven't researched this i
no other lawyers may have
to survive an undue burden challenge
under the commerce clause
thank you representative ames as you
said it's a complicated
topic
part of what complicates it is
distinguishing
income taxes from other taxes
income tax on personal income versus
business income
distinguishing
income that may be earned as a w-2
employee versus as a 1099 contractor
versus as a pass-through
business entity
using the benefit of
sub-chapter s or llc
or sole proprietorship so it's a very
complicated area
i don't know whether we have solved it
i hope that we have come as close to the
it's
intended
to clearly refer to
taxation of personally earned income
and the purpose of the second and third
paragraphs is to make a distinction with
the business tax
where i don't think it's so much that we
tax activity elsewhere it's that we take
account of all activity and we use
certainly certain formulas and
proportions which are in common use
across the country
so
time will tell
how successful we we are
but at the moment there is nothing in
our law that would uh help lay the
foundation for a similar lawsuit if the
we have a representation from the dra
does the dra have any comments on what
representative ames and representative
good morning my name is king ming wong
tax policy council from the department
of revenue agency administration
we haven't specifically looked into the
commerce clause consequences of this
bill
our main objective was to ensure that
any language that was proposed in this
bill would not negatively impact the the
operations and the administration of the
business
taxes that we currently have
so
that's the purpose of the the additional
two chapter additional two sections
representative army
oh representative ames
the difficulty that uh we face as a
committee right now is that uh
we've just received this amendment
and although it's just three
long sentences or maybe there's a couple
more in there
it's
complicated as you just said and
if indeed the
objective is to
narrow the scope to
income that's subject to income taxes
per se
and not business taxes
we could work on this language to
improve it
if we had time
i gather we don't have time
because we're here and uh i think this
afternoon is the deadline for
filing reports on bills like this
so we've run out of time and an option
is interim study i imagine that's not
uh that's frowned on um
or
may be objected to um
but that to me would be preferable
there's no urgency to this whatsoever
that i know of as you've pointed out
massachusetts has backed away from
the
initiative during covid that
led to litigation and so that's not on
the table anymore no one is trying to
tax the personal income earned by
new hampshire residents
for doing work in new hampshire
for out of state firms and then being
taxed by the out of state
by that state
so i i don't think there's any urgency i
know interim study right now means
a year of study and then a bill and a
new legislature next year and that may
not be uh
what you want but
why not
do a good job with the language
thank you representative ames
representative alani
thank you uh
i have a question for
attorney wong
but first i wanted to
i think
that purpose
is
um
something that they usually take out of
the bills when they put them into the
law
and i can't remember if we've ever put
purpose into the law
in which case
if it was taken out this wouldn't make
any sense so
uh
has anyone looked into that
um representative olerie seems to
think
yeah
go ahead
uh representative all me there are
several instances where the the general
court
has put in the purpose or intent
uh when you say uh purpose in this uh
section it's actually an intense section
yeah so that's
yeah that we've done that before on a
wide range laws mostly criminal but
you know this is tax law so might as
well say what it's about thank you
thank you could i
first the second question though on
representative hollery has seen this so
um
i wanted to ask attorney wong
if
you see any chance
that
could take
sections two and three of this versus
section one and start a lawsuit about
i don't expect that the that the issues
would arise from sections two and three
because the sections two entries
specifically just um says that
uh to
to maintain the integrity of our uh bptn
bet
chapters so um
so if any i really don't expect that
there's any
any tax practitioner
would just parse out
sections two and three
and make a challenge
there's no language in there that would
contradict
our existing statutes
could i clarify
don't don't two and three acknowledge
that we are doing something
related and together with section one
acknowledge that we are doing something
that is uh
opposed to what we're asking others to
do
are you saying that i'm so
section so the issues with with section
one then
well with the combination combination
thereof
maybe if we'd hidden two and three
somewhere else oh okay
um
yes so with without two and three um
section one
still still works but i was just so our
concern is that tax partition
practitioners that we've seen in the
past
would potentially could potentially read
section one
so
usually the
statutory interpretation is to read the
statute as it is
and
and apply it as it is but we have seen
in in our practice that um
in our agency that some tax
practitioners would read a certain
statute and somehow read the inverse
to be accurate and to be law as well so
what the statute might say okay uh
text might be not applicable to this
situation and then they will read it
okay so the inverse would be
true then
so that's the purpose of having uh
sections two and three so to avoid any
kind of inverse reading of section one
i don't know if that answers a question
not really because it's such a
complicated area behind this
fairly simple language thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman
i want to call everyone's attention to
line 10 of the amendment
and if we look at line 10
the end of that
line where it says
for services entirely performed within
the state of new hampshire may
not be subject so the word may
i want to call attention to that word
because previously the word was shall
and so
one of the things that the attorney
general's office
wanted to change was the word from shall
to may to soften this
it would be less likely that someone
misinterprets this
but
still
moving this forward gives them the
ability if they have to to go back to
the supreme court and so i think that
word may
softens it and
and
should
make this less
much less of a concern than when the
word shall was there
and just as a further comment i'd like
to say that while massachusetts has
backed off and right this minute there
the issue is if some other problem comes
up who knows where this
whole energy issue is going maybe it
gets to the point where people don't
want to drive people are at home again
massachusetts comes back again and says
hey we're back to that same thing again
and we don't have the time
we can't react who knows how long it's
going to take us to react it's going to
be at least a year until we can react to
that so i would i would propose that we
move forward uh with this
and we and we take note of the word may
in line 10. thank you
thank you mr chair um thank you for
pointing out the word may which makes
rubbed on ames
yeah
representative uhler is always uh
so
precise in his wording
uh
that i uh i'm left scratching my head
uh so
thank you for that um
and it really i think is uh is the
question i was going to raise uh
if you
emphasize that word may
which is
apparently uh
a critical component of this redraft
um
then you've taken haven't you taken the
guts out of this whole thing and the
supreme court
is not going to go forward on a
matter where
where it's sort of discretionary whether
the state will do something it's only if
if new hampshire interprets this as a
shell in a particular context
does something to some corporation
that there'll be an issue sufficient for
the supreme court to take it on
and uh so i think that uh
that understanding further
uh persuades me that this bill
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to
respond to several different comments
that have been made
first of all
i do not understand this may shell
distinction the same way it's just been
described
you may not do something means you can't
second
i acknowledge the tension
between the personal income tax position
and
perhaps it would be better to have the
word position
instead of purpose at the beginning of
paragraph 78 f1 position is the word
that's used in line three describing the
chapter
and again in line six in the caption
so i don't think that's really ambiguous
what's being done here
the tension is inherent in the problem
and i had preferred that we not have the
second and third paragraphs but i
consider them to be essentially harmless
they don't detract from paragraph one
and
i think that
one could
potentially critique or handicap
the potency of paragraph one if the
situation arises i would rather have
representative tucker
yeah i
i'm afraid
representative genegan got to my point
uh but i wanted to amplify it and that
is that
because of the particular time now in
international relations with russia and
uh
the invasion of ukraine
it certainly has made us much more aware
of
the rapidity with which
energy prices can arise
just the way two years ago we learned
about the rapidity
of how
the reaction to the pandemic
and the vast changes that have taken
place
so it's true that
we first were thinking of this in terms
of the pandemic and that we had time to
react
and it there was no rush
but i'm thinking that really the last
couple of years have taught us that
things happen rapidly
and we need to be prepared
presumably
as this goes forward to the senate
there'd be chances to
tweak some language
but i would feel more comfortable
if we had a reaction
now
and
i'm interested in seeing whether we can
represented hacking phillips
thank you mr chair
i think it's just an important moment
for the committee to reflect possibly on
the general hypothetical
confronting us as a state if we set up a
law that tries to tell other states what
it can and cannot do
does that open the door for a
neighboring state to set up a law
to tell us what we can and cannot do and
uh you know just going through that
exercise in your own mind right now i'm
sure we can all come up with scenarios
that would be really unpleasant
for all of us and i think
you know the the tax consequences to our
taxpayers for proposing laws
that are known to be
litigated
on such a premise
is probably
not expedient at this moment and i do
think that the idea is valuable
to research further and i i definitely
side with representative ames in this
position
uh that more
more needs to be done
at the ag's office to assure us that the
language we're proposing is worth um
you know backing
fully in this lang you know in this
amendment if this is the law that we'd
like to move forward with
i i do think that the timing is just too
quick to reach that um
level of comfortability at this moment
you know i think we're setting ourselves
up for
quite a fight and i'm not sure we're
putting ourselves in the best position
to make that fight successful so those
are my those are my thoughts thank you
mr chair
thank you
uh further comments representing julie
thank you mr chair uh
to
representative hacken phillips of last
comment
states tell people
of other states what they can and can't
do all the time for example you can't
drive in massachusetts without putting
your seat belt on
that's
part of
the federal system we have is that
various different activities can be
controlled in this particular
uh situation
area
we're telling a state that they can't
tax
somebody
for work that they've done an individual
for work that they have done
with within the confines of this state
even if it is engaged in international
activity
i'm kind of reminded of my father who
worked for
hugh greg more than
uh
when they were sold to tripac
he was being paid out of pennsylvania
which had an income tax
but no income tax was taken out because
it's triangle pacific um what's the name
of the company and i think what we're
trying to do here is to reassert
long-standing irs regulations
or rules
which state
the work done within the state is taxed
on is taxed by the state where the work
was done
not
what we're saying is if you're doing the
work
and maybe for a in this case
massachusetts company you still can't
tax it because all the work was done in
new hampshire even if you were entering
it on a spreadsheet that got sent
someplace else when you finished doing
your analysis of whatever whatever
you were doing in that time
making sales calls or
doing customer service work on an hourly
basis or whatever
so long as the work was done in new
hampshire
and i do agree with representative ames
that the word may
um
kind of
moves us to nothingness
when you say
excuse me may not do
is one thing
but this is not saying that that you may
not do
it says
in this case the word may has its
alternative meaning
which there's a permissiveness element
maybe it can be maybe you can't we don't
know we don't care we're gonna
that's why it becomes moved because it's
not saying
you shall not
tax and if you try to that gives new
hampshire standing to
defend the individual against the
encroachment of a foreign state
thank you sir thank you representative
and representative nunes
thank you mr chairman um i read it
i read it as if it gives the state of
new hampshire the right to defend itself
as a sovereign state period that's the
way i read it
and uh and i would think that that the
other two sections that are in there um
are only in there as protectionism
against those two those those two types
of taxes
um
so if we think about giving uh giving
the state the right to defend itself
against what i would call an outside tax
an outside attack on its tax system then
um and maybe we should look at it that
represents uh long
lachman thank you
i agree with representative uluri about
uh the word may taking the teeth right
out of it and i think you know we can
look to the attorney general making that
suggestion
um as you know an indication that there
is a distinct difference between shall
not and may not
um i agree with that
i think if we want
uh a right to defend ourselves if we
want the power to uh enforce it we're
gonna need a court ruling and if we want
a court ruling i agree with
representative ames that this would have
to have teeth and i think using the word
may
uh nullifies it a little bit i don't
think we'll get to that stage with that
language
anybody
knew
representative followed by
representative spillsbury
thank you i
do think i think all of us
think that this is a really important
issue with a very long time horizon at
this point well very long
maybe two years three years five years
because
more and more people are going to be
going remote
and that creates other problems more
problems even than the ones that this is
trying to address certainly than the
very narrow massachusetts law
and i think that if we want to get this
to a point where the supreme court would
be forced
to
uh the u.s supreme court would be forced
to on
work with us on this and figure out how
to do this nationally we need more
allies than just ourselves to try to go
there especially
on
with well
especially no just with a bill that one
state with an odd tax system
uh is asking
for
it is a very odd tax system
would
be
asking to have resolved i think that we
need the dra needs time to talk with tax
attorneys
from
other revenue departments all across the
country about this issue
of on
more and more people living in one place
and
try to see if there are allies to bring
forward
forward on
something that is going to allow
this uh force the supreme court to take
up an issue that they probably aren't
going to want to take up because it's
very very complicated
so okay
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman
this this of course is a case of people
living
and working in the same place
in new hampshire
the essential
distinction between the bill is
originally drafted
and this amendment is that the bills are
was aimed at massachusetts or any other
state that would take a similar position
and it's because we don't have the power
to control
their actions that it got reframed the
purpose of it as drafted in the
amendment
is to
unequivocally
state
the policy and the sovereign interest
so that it can be defended and so i just
want to echo representative nunez's
comments that the purpose of the
amendment is not so much to tell
massachusetts what it can and cannot do
it's to tell new hampshire
that we are going to defend
this sovereign interest as as enunciated
here
as far as you know may versus shao
i don't read it that way but i would be
glad to work with the senate to put the
word shaolin in place of may and remove
all doubt
the last comment i just want to make the
observation so that the committee is
aware
that when this language was
worked out yesterday morning
assistant attorney general sam garland
personally took it to reviewed it with
attorney general formella and got his
sign off
so i would like us to go ahead and if
there are reservations let's work with
thank you representative spellsbury
representing you
yes i just want to echo what
representative spillsbury just said we
the two of us worked with dra and the
attorney general's office and
um
that's absolutely true we worked with
sam garland he took it to the attorney
general yesterday the attorney general
approved of this language so
um
it's i think it's and they would prefer
something as to rather than nothing and
they would prefer this in case something
else comes up they're ready to go
and we still have the possibility of
improving it further in the senate so i
also would say let's uh move ahead with
this thank you
thank you representation eugene
any further questions or comments i have
a question for representative ames
representative ames from the discussion
that we had this morning
all the reasons for and and not
in your opinion
is there a fix
that you would like to see immediately
that can be addressed immediately
because we must exact this today
i'm not prepared to do that right now
that's uh this is as has been said by
many people
complicated it looks simple but it's
complicated and uh
you know what i i'd love to have the
opportunity to do is what we did if
you'll recall you were here
when we dealt with the uh wayfarer
matter and uh if you'll remember
those who were around
uh that all started in
the summer of one year i don't remember
which years we're at with a special
session on a special committee
focus on the bill i was on that
committee a number of others
uh
at then council for the governor
formella was uh a key person and
drafting a bill that went before the
house and the senate and failed it
wasn't ready it wasn't quite right we
all reckon well we didn't all recognize
it i think the house voted for it but
the senate voted it down
and then another bill was introduced
and i came to this committee
and we worked if you'll remember we had
several work sessions on that bill
with
attorney formula and with bill lardinger
a well-known tax attorney and
constitutional attorney law
constitutional law attorney
and we made substantial changes in that
bill as we work through it the goal
being
to set up a system that would enable new
hampshire
to go forward to the supreme court much
like this bill is being developed
uh in a way that could uh make a
difference for new hampshire
if in fact uh
sales tax activity in that case what was
involved
threatened new hampshire's sovereign
interests
we worked out a good system a good bill
we were all happy with that it went
through and was enacted but it was
substantially different from what came
to us that fall that's the kind of work
we need in this case and
i appreciate that
the attorney general now attorney
general formula
took a look at this and said yes
he supported this
but that's very different from sitting
down
working through the complexities and
making sure we've got something
it's not cheap to go to the supreme
court it costs a lot of money
and
to go forward with litigation
is something you don't do lightly so uh
i think you want to go forward with us
with litigation with a strong hand and
that's the way i'd prefer to do it and
not rely on maybe negotiating a fix with
the
state senate
so that's my response to that
thank you representative ames we're
going to take a
five minute recess at this point
uh well we're gonna
want to caucus i think but i just if i
could make a final comment on this
on
what i'm really worried about is that
you pass this the way it is which is
fairly innocuous because um
attorney general formella didn't want to
and
and then we forget about it we don't
bother to do anything with it
on we do have wayfarer totally set up
for when
the big state this big sales tax states
start going after the smallest sellers
in other
states
but and
that's why you don't hear much about it
today they aren't doing it yet at least
that's what the businesses tell us
and
but
we
this is not
sufficient to be able to get the supreme
okay we're going to take a
five-minute break and uh
can we have at least 10 minutes we need
to have a caucus
we do too
15 minutes maybe um
we'll be back we'll be back in ten
we're gonna go find the room on this
floor i think we can when we finish when
we finish this we'll have that here
okay the republicans want to stay in
here
i just want to uh apologize for holding
everything up here
uh i'll just say we was we're defending
the house position in the senate
so
uh so i apologize for the delay
by the way they were nice enough to move
the last bill up one
so i could be here even quicker thank
you okay we're going to go into
go into executive session on house bill
1097 representative spellsbury
thank you mr chairman uh on
hb 1097 i move out to pass as amended by
first of all you move out to pass on
1097.
i do i move out to pass on 1097. do we
have a second
second
representative spillsboard you have
another amendment
yes mr chairman i would like to move
adoption of
one amendment
three seven h
a second
representative spellsbury you want to
i believe we've had sufficient
discussion thank you very much mr
chairman
thank you president spielsberg any other
comments or questions on the amendment
being done all those in favor raise
okay
all right uh we'll take a
roll call you want to call the vote on
the amendment
sure this is amendment 2022
we'll begin the voting with
representative abrami
yes
representative true yes representative
owery
yes representative doucette yes
representative lange yes
bershteen votes yes jeanigan yes
representative nunes yes representative
spillsbury yes representative wallace
yes
representative aaron
yes representative all me
no
representative ames
representative ebel
yes
representative schomburg no
representative tucker yes
representative gomarlo no
representative laughman
yes
representative wilhelm
representative hacken phillips no
representative murphy no
the vote on the amendment
of
17-6 about to pass and so it passes
now
we're on the bill as
amendment as amended
in the
so with
amendment 1037h
i see
representative
evil evil and i realize i'm a sub and i
you you're not you're not supposed to
talk if you're a sub but um i just want
to and i haven't been in the previous
hearings i just want to clarify that
even though the state of massachusetts
um
situation shown a bright light on the
issue of
other states
charging income tax for people that work
within the state
the state of new york has had this
policy in a very aggressive way for many
many years and there are many people
that work remotely
in this state that are associated with
new york corporations that have had to
pay the income tax
so it's not like this was something
new
it's the thing that many state well i
don't know how many states do it i know
that new york state does it
personally
so i just wanted to get it on the record
for clarification's sake
thank you any further discussion or
comments
representing elmi
just like to add that they were doing
this when i was a child in new york
and um
they
um
and
this um
we
certainly must at this point because the
pandemic have people living here
permanently that are
working in new york city
i know that there were in fact people in
the north country
that regarded this as their home state
even though they spent most their time
in new york
thank you
any further comments or questions
all right
mr
yeah
that was for the amendment
oh right no now you have to make an otpa
motion
mr chairman thank you
as amended
so the motion is ought to pass as
amended
with amendment
thank you mr chair
the bill is hb 1097
the motion is ought to pass as amended
we'll begin the roll call vote with
representative abrami
yes
representative true yes
representative already yes
representative doucette yes
representative lang yes representative
bershteen votes yes representative
genigion yes representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury
representative wallace yes
representative aaron
yes
representative almi
no
representative ames
representative ebel yes representative
malloy yes
representative schamberg the
representative from nottingham has such
a great voice
no
thank you sir
representative tucker yes representative
gomarlo no
representative laughman yes
representative wilhelm yes
representative hacken phillips
no
representative murphy no
we've all been 17-6 the motion about to
pass with amendment 1037h
passes
yeah who's going to do the minority
report
representative hackman phillips
and just to be clear representative
hacking phillips your motion will be for
as opposed to
itl
the next is house bill 1221
relative to the rights of the business
profits tax and the business enterprise
tax
uh representative tunisian
thank you mr chairman i make a motion of
ought to pass on hb 1221.
second
second by
lebrony
do i hear another motion
i'd like to make a motion um on an
amendment to hb
amendment number
2022-0471
h
i want to speak to your motion on the
amendment yeah yes thank you mr chairman
so this amendment the original bill
um
basically
lowered the business profits tax from
7.6 percent to 7.5 percent and the bet
business enterprise tax
from 0.55 to 0.5
there was a concern that given the tax
cuts in the previous year
the um
while business profits are up tax
revenues to the state are up
the
impact of the ppp loans
and the stimulus packages
make it a little bit difficult to know
exactly where we stand
so
the amendment basically takes out the
reduction in the bet tax
and moves forward only with the lowering
of the bpt tax
so
the amendment basically lowers the
business profits tax from 7.6 to 7.5
percent
and um
it's it's basically um we become very
competitive it was a
um
a goal that was put forth approximately
six years ago when
the business profits tax was 8.5 it's
the goal back then was to get it down to
7.5 we are at 7.6 this would be the
final 0.1
reduction
and we will compare very favorably with
our neighbors in massachusetts that have
an eight percent business profits tax
and our neighbors in vermont whose tax
varies between six and eight and a half
percent and it gets to eight and a half
percent as soon as it's over twenty five
thousand so for all practical purposes
they would be virtually a percent higher
so i would urge um
passage of this amendment for those
reasons
further comments on the amendment
representative
schamberg
i know i've been in florida for two
weeks it's tough to remember any names
uh rip uh a question for the
representative canadian
you said this was a goal
you've reached that goal is that the
position of the party now not to go
i'm not gonna i'm not going to speak to
further goals at this point right now
this is the this is the goal at hand and
this is um
what we're what we're uh aiming for
thank you sir
further questions and comments
representative me
thank you bye representative
on
i would also like to know
uh
well point out actually on
that it is
already impossible so this probably
won't make it any worse to
estimate our revenues because the single
sales factor is hitting next year we
have no idea what it's going to do
except that the largest corporations are
probably no longer going to pay bpt
and the manufacturing corporations
on
and we have a lot of other things that
we've done that
make it we still don't we'll never know
what market-based sourcing did
so
we are now in complete i i
i just want to tell dra that on
that we know you're going to have an
impossible time trying to estimate
revenues and so are we
representative
thank you mr chair um i'd just like to
reiterate what i've said in the past two
work sessions that you're giving a break
to the multinationals
and not to our small businesses
and the small businesses are the ones
that went through hell the last two
and i realized the impact on revenue is
greater giving that
0.05
reduction to the small businesses
versus the 0.1 percent to the bigger
businesses
but
i think the dollars that are saved by
those smaller businesses will stay here
in new hampshire versus what you're
giving to the big businesses that
have admitted they don't always notice
what they're paying for their business
taxes
so are they going to notice their 0.1
percent reduction whereas a small
business in new hampshire
would notice their 0.05 reduction
thank
you further comments
representative elmi i mean
romney followed by representation
i just want to i just want to speak for
the majority caucus here
that i think this caucus has shown a lot
of restraint this year we had an
opportunity to
to
get rid of the car rental tax
we chose not to
we had a chance to get rid of the
communication tax
we chose not to
and we also had a chance to lower the
bet tax and we chose not to
so
i think we're being very prudent
this this is not
uh the reason we this was a goal from
years ago that we i think symbolically
is important
to to get this tax down to 7.5 percent
and it's only going to cost i think i
don't have the
i think it's is it 8 million 8 million
right but
we understand representative uh the
minority leader
position
about and we we understand all the
things you mentioned and we that's why
we've shown restraint
and not not lowering some of these other
taxes at this point in time thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman yeah i would just
like to make the point that the uh the
bpt tax and the bet tax are paid by both
businesses both large and small
it's not as though
somehow the big businesses avoid the be
tax so
this is a this is a tax lowering
to 7.5 will help small business as well
thank you
yeah i just want to
well
first i i want to uh uh
acknowledge representative romney's
point that the majority has shown
shown restraint
dealing with
bills that call for
tax cuts in this
year's
work on bills so i appreciate that but
nonetheless we are faced with a bill
that does
uh
add another increment to the cuts and
taxes that have been made
of about 8 million once it gets up to
full speed uh
per year and uh
that's
a significant amount of money uh when
added to all the other amounts of money
that are
lost through the other cuts
and
this effort needs to be
viewed in the context of uh
what's happening on the property tax
front
we have to look at all taxes
and uh although it's uneven and that's
why i think each of us sees a different
uh picture
you look at it from where you sit and
stand and live
so if you're in a
town that's
got
a high property to property taxable
wealth
you're likely going to have low property
taxes and maybe even have benefited in
the last two years from the
efforts that have been made to send
money down to municipalities but if
you're in a low property wealth
town and some of us are
we've seen a different picture and our
businesses and our residential owner our
owners of uh homes
are facing property tax increases
that
i'd say without exaggeration in some
cases dwarf
the business tax
cuts
uh
just uh a couple of days ago
last friday uh at the
forum economic forum that
was convened by representative major and
others
uh a business owner from jeffrey from my
town
spoke and when asked
said that what he worries about when he
looks at earth property tax
uh consequences and costs
and that the business tax really isn't
something he he pays much attention to
he runs a manufacturing facility small
that's his perspective
so we're cutting the wrong tax we should
be
thinking about uh state aid to
school districts and
towns that really need it making sure
we've got formulas that send it to the
right place
and i think a bill like this it's just
an increment but it's eight million
dollars goes in the wrong direction and
so that's why i'm going to vote against
it
thank you representatives any further
representative romney
thank you mr chair
you know
this this past budget
they were let me mention two things that
we did in that budget first
for for years the state aid to the towns
was in the
low 20s
this year in the budget
we had to compromise we've increased it
to
30 percent so the towns are going to get
more more stated than they ever have
before
some wanted to be 40. i was actually a
co-sponsor for the bill to make it 40
but the compromise was was 30
then we did something rather unique in
the second year of the budget
is that we took 100 million dollars
because we had such a surplus
we wanted to make sure there was true
tax relief to the to taxpayers property
taxpayers we took 100 million dollars
and we put that over from the general
fund into the education trust fund
but when the dra
did their calculation instead of the
three 361 million
that's swept
they're basing that calculation on 261.
and that guarantees that everybody's
it's not big number when you when you
look at all the communities but it's
still something
that we did to reduce property tax rates
for for folks so we're trying
uh
and yes we have a ways to go to try to
find ways to continue to do that
but
that last way was unique in that we made
sure that that money
went back to
the
property taxpayers thank you mr chair
further questions or comments
representative elneny
thank you
the way that that we did a hundred
thousand hundred million
on the term before and it was sent to
the school districts that had the most
the highest
costs the
compared to their property
on it went to the places that needed it
most
this hundred million went to the
communities which had the greatest
property wealth
which means to the richest communities
most
on my
community of lebanon
has
a huge
amount of
commercial property industrial property
and um and
our housing prices are going up but
they're nowhere near hanovers
uh
and
on our property taxes are
pretty high but because of that wealth
we balanced out this year
people aren't noticing that when they
they are
so
um
but the communities around me
have our bedroom communities they have a
lot less
only hanover is wealthy but on
the others are varying degrees of
low and middle
income
mostly and they
they suffer more and of course claremont
suffers a great deal more they are not
helped by this i doubt charleston is
helped by this
thank you
representative model
i just
i if i remember correctly deputy
commissioner lear said that
all bpt payers did not necessarily pay
the bet she didn't elaborate on
on those uh
circumstances but
someone asked directly and and she said
no that's not necessarily so so i just
any further
comments or questions
saying none i'm going to ask the
court to call the vote on the amendment
thank you mr chair we will begin the
roll call vote with representative
abrami yes
representative true yes
representative hollery yes
representative doucette yes
representative lang yes bershteen votes
yes
representative genigean yes
representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative wallis yes representative
aaron
yes
representative army no
representative ames no
representative ebel no
representative malloy
no
representative schomburg no
representative tucker no
representative gomarlo no
representative laughman
no
representative wilhelm no
representative hacken phillips no
representative murphy
no
the vote being 12-11 the amendment
passes
we are now on the
house bill 1221
and
representative
you made the motion
yes i make the motion of opt
out to pass on how to spill 12 21 as
amended
second
and seconded by representative romney
any
seeing none i'll ask the court to call
the vote on opt to pass as amended with
amendment 041h
thank you mr chair the bill is
house bill 1221
otpa we'll begin the roll call vote with
representative abrami yes
representative true yes representative
hollery yes representative doucet yes
representative lang yes bershteen votes
yes janigan yes
nunes yes representative spillsbury yes
representative wallace yes
representative aaron yes
representative army
no
representative ames no
representative evil no
representative malloy bill
the honorable thomas representative
thomas c schomberg
no
it's like hearing angels sing you can't
get me with that sweet voice okay
representative tucker
no
representative go marlow no
representative laughman no
representative wilhelm no
representative hacken phillips no
representative murphy no
the motion about to pass on house bill
1221 as amended with
041h
passes by a vote of 12 to 11.
and it definitely will be on the regular
calendar
mr chair and who's
uh you mis uh spoke on the amendment
number i think i believe you said oh
one four seven one h right
zero four one seven seven one yeah thank
you
establishing a national service alumni
attraction and retention fund
representative spillsbury
thank you mr chairman i'd like to make a
motion
on hb 1524
of itl
representative spellsbury makes a motion
of itl and house bill 1524
do i have a second
representative spielberg you want to
talk to your motion
thank you mr chairman
first of all i want to thank uh diligent
members of the
democratic caucus who've put a lot of
time into this and
i appreciate it um representative
wilhelm it's good to have you here today
when your bill's
taken up and
representative schomburg representative
murphy
you're a delight to work with
so
i have appreciated that this has been
something that we've discussed a fair
bit
outside of committee session
and certainly was my hope
to
clarify any critiques that i had made
and to
give you know full opportunity for them
to be addressed and in fact i think that
through four amendments there have been
steady improvements the bill is
far better off um
with the most recent
amendment from representative murphy and
i would suggest
that regardless of the final outcome on
the bill
that we should adopt the amendments so
that the bill is in its best position
nevertheless
i think the bill still has
some serious
flaws
and and i say this with full respect to
the
quality of those individuals who choose
to serve in the peace corps and
americorps and
to use the term of the bill
satisfactorily complete their terms of
service
they of course
have an arrangement
through that program
stipend
they get an enormous amount of valuable
experience from a work
force development perspective
i believe that they emerge from their
two years in peace corps of their year
in
in americorps um much better positioned
to join the workforce
so there's a there's certainly a
sympathetic position behind the bill in
terms of supporting those who go on for
further education or those who seek
employment and i understand that it's a
principally a retention program for
out-of-state employees
but it still lacks a lot in terms of
describing the mechanics it's not clear
to me what action it is that the
educational institution
or the employer
has to take to and to trigger the match
or how it's demonstrated
uh
it's been clarified
that the
amount
of up to three thousand and potentially
six thousand is based on per term of
service
there's nothing in the bill that
indicates how these payments are
extended in relation to terms of study
whether that's a semester or a year or
a multi-year program
there's no criteria
really for
the the variance
in discretion of granting 300 to 3 000
unless perhaps it's meant that that
depends entirely on
how much is being matched that's not
even clear
i think one of the other
unfortunate things in the bill is that
it's been represented as a three-year
pilot
um
program but there's no sunset
it's been represented as requiring 750
000 over three years at two hundred
fifty thousand a year
but it seeks to uh
uh have seven hundred fifty thousand
dollars of funds set aside all at once
in fy23
which is unbudgeted of course
and
it it seems to me the way it's written
that it suggests to the governor that he
might look to see if there's available
our upper funds but it doesn't require
him to find the funds there
therefore it appears to me to be a
unbudgeted unappropriated
expenditure so i just think that the
bill has too many flaws to allow it to
go ahead
and i say that with total respect for
thank you representative spillsbury
whether
questions or comments
representative murphy
uh
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
representative spillsbury um
certainly in an era of really
partisan politics it's been a pleasure
to pass back and forth uh some of the
comments and the amendments that have
been worked on um i i think as talking
to representative wilhelm about the bill
the intent was not to get too deeply
into the weed so to speak as to the
details
but in an effort within the amendment it
was made to basically state that
a term of service was a term of service
either in the americorps peace corps not
necessarily related to anything
regarding a term in a college or
university
the intent was also that the peace corps
americorps have different lengths of
time in service
that length of time and service may be
compromised by a geopolitical problem
say if you are in the peace corps in
ukraine right now that may you know
interrupt your time of service and they
shorten it substantially and therefore
there was a certain
uh
laxity in the amount of monies that
would be matched to
support these individuals
but satisfactory completion of service
is actually determined by the rules and
certifications of both americorps and
peace corps
and we were trying to leave it at that
point to have them determine who has or
who has not completed a successful term
of service
it was also the intent that again
without becoming
too
heavily detailed
and prescriptive in its
rollout
that an eligible student had to have
received a grant or a
scholarship from a university
or have spent at least one year of
service in the employment of the
employer's business
uh those were stipulations that were
made in whatever the college or
university or the employer gave in debt
relief for college and education
that monies would be matched um out of
opera funds without any implication or
any impact on the general fund or the
educational trust fund
uh to the same dollar amount not to
exceed in the lifetime of their
participation any more than six thousand
dollars
um
so i think the amendment again with
representative spillsbury's
encouragement uh we did put a finer
point on some of the questions that were
raised
i i also reflect on this in a sense of
the intent of the build you know at the
at a 50 000 foot level is really the
intent to recruit and retain what i
would consider i think we would all
agree are very qualified
quality high valued committed
individuals whether they are in graduate
studies or in
in their employment
we know
by a lot of the data that we see from
various organizations in the state
people graduating from high school tend
to leave the state and do not return if
they do come back into graduate studies
college or employment bring in their
family
there's a much greater chance that these
folks will stay in the state
last week we heard from
dan white from moody's and also phil
slatten from the
fiscal policy institute
since we have been involved in the
pandemic our number of the jobs have
returned to the state but shockingly
we have lagged way behind in job
participation we are at 97 where the
country is at around 99
that's a huge problem for our state with
an aging population
increasing retirement
and young individuals leaving the state
and not returning we are setting
ourselves up to have a very significant
job force problem
the intent of the bill
is is really in somebody actually
brought up in the committee in one of
the work sessions why do we want to be
the first in the country to establish
this sort of program i would argue if
you're number 50 in the country with
regard to
job participation we ought to be looking
at those numbers and really addressing
those with any program we can
if in fact we are putting forward opera
monies without any implication to the
general trust fund the educational trust
fund if we are bringing back mature
qualif quality people
to study here and or work here
if we are doing this without any impact
to the general fund or any other or any
other funding here
why would we not do that yes it is a
three-year trial
if it is successful then i think the
next step logical step would be to look
for alternative funding
to help you know support this whether
it's public or private that could be
determined later but i think we will not
know that unless we actually trial it so
i i appreciate that i think what the
intent was and again i i'm respectful of
your comments we were trying not to get
so deeply involved in the wordage but i
think it is clear that these are arpa
funds
that if a
school or university pro is working
within the coverdell fellowship programs
or the americorps schools of service
program or if an employer is enrolled in
the employers of national service
program there are certain guidelines
with which they are working within in
order to give grants and or monies to
these individuals
i think in this state we are clearly at
a point where we need to focus on our
workforce
we focus on housing but we don't have a
housing problem if we don't have a
workforce so unless we really start
thinking about this in starting to
initiate programs
i i think we're going to find ourselves
in a very difficult position going
forward so i would
i would encourage and hope that people
would support this bill uh
representative wilhelm has put a lot of
effort into this and i think as will you
as we all agree and as you mentioned
representative bill is very the the
motion or the motive behind this is
laudatory and i think that we ought to
you know
step forward to help our uh universities
and colleges and our employers bring in
excellent people into these systems
thank you
thank you representative murphy
representative longman
thank you mr chairman you know
just within the hour we execute a bill
that we believed in and its intent and
it wasn't perfect but we knew we could
fix it in the senate uh we agreed on
that
um and the last bill we talked about you
know how we can help business and we
thought
yet another shaving of a fraction off of
a business profits tax was the best way
to help business but
when i talk to business
every single time the first and foremost
issue that comes up is workforce
this bill actually does address that
problem so
you know
if we can focus and prioritize
initiatives
efforts bills like this that help to
attract and retain workforce in this
state
that's going to go
a lot farther in my opinion and i i
would wager many business owners opinion
than yet another fraction of a point
off of attacks that they didn't ask for
now how you feel about that doesn't
matter but i'd say
workforce related uh initiatives like
this is huge for business and
and that's why i'm going to support it
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman on what the
employer has to do to trigger this
is in the bill
on they have to enroll in a national
program
called on several of them employers of
national service
and the americorps schools of service or
the peace corps cover dell fellows
program
on i think one of the intents of what
they want to do besides
proving this concept
is to get
more businesses in new hampshire
involved in
the these retention and training
programs that will give them the
workforce they need
and
on
and in enrolling in those programs as
business owners
on
the
the other
there is no
sunset because the idea was
that they figured that they would go
through about 250 000 a year
uh
seven hundred and fifty thousand over
three years versus eight million that we
just spent per year
on this one percent point one percent
concept
um
and it sets the 700
the way we've rewritten it
it sets the 750 000
aside at this at one time
and no there is no sunset the sunset
would be if they cannot attract funding
later probably from business groups
to keep this going because it is a
reliable source of new labor
that is
yes it is unbudgeted but the way this
legislature has always worked is that it
to put that money in
and
in this particular case
because
it would
the idea the sponsor's idea was never to
take it out of the general fund it was
to go after money that is in arpa that
covers this
and
the governor
has control of the arpa funds the
governor would have to decide whether
he's actually going to appropriate that
money out of the arpa fund
if this bill passes it seems likely he
would since he has a representative on
volunteer new hampshire
and
he also
cares about the workforce
i wanted also there there was an email
that you got
uh oh it was at noon yesterday so maybe
some people read it
from gretchen stalin's the executive
director of volunteer new hampshire
pointing out
the very large number of
dollars
three million dollars a year that
they regularly
grant and disperse
to
two different groups of people drift
around
the state
on behalf of the federal government
they know how to do this
and it
city year new hampshire coalition
against domestic and sexual violence
goodwill industries squam lakes
epilepsy foundation new england student
conservation association goodwill
industries
campus contact compact for new hampshire
united way of greater nashua animal
rescue league new hampshire belknap
county conservation district friends
forever inc
girl scouts of the green and white
mountains haven violence prevention and
support services lakes region community
developers merrimack river
watershed council and willinghands which
is something in my area
these are all
non-profits around the state
on they have they want to get more into
helping with the general economy
and
this would give them three years to try
it out if the governor approves of it
thank you
oh boy
that's because we're getting more like
family
all right anybody else wish to uh
more questions or comments
if not we're going to call the vote on
itl
on 1524.
thank you mr chair we will begin the
roll call vote with representative
representative true yes representative
ulrich yes representative ducette yes
representative lang yes representative
bershteen votes yes representative
genigion yes representative nunes yes
representative spillsbury yes
representative wallace yes
representative aaron yes
representative army no
representative ames so
representative ebel no
representative malloy no
representative thomas c schomburg i wish
my brother from nottingham and i could
agree but no
so do i
representative tucker
no
representative gomarlo
representative laughman no
representative wilhelm
no
representative hacken phillips no
representative murphy
no
chairman major yes
the vote been
12 yes and 11 no
the motion of itl on 1524 passes
it will go on the regular calendar and
do we have who's going to write the
okay
we are thrilled with our executive
session
and we can go on to the recess hearing
representative wallace
you don't need to stay if you don't want
okay
yes
all the committee members are going to
be writing the blurbs i need the blurbs
by two this afternoon
both the majority and the minority
reports
if they're not then we'll go
okay we want to get started with a
recess hearing
so those that aren't going to stay if
oh
okay we have a substitute clerk for a
few minutes
uh the first
the prime sponsor representative ladd
and representative it's yours thank you
very much uh chairman major and members
of the ways and means committee
i i see your clerk is back he enjoyed
being with us in education yesterday
till six o'clock last night in the
previous day
of course we do have a clerk
and we have
one that's
on deck and one's in the hole and we
have three clerks and we've used them
all and burned them out
so i'd like to introduce 1584 for the
record my name is rick ladd i hail from
haverhill new hampshire
behavioral that's in new hampshire not
the one in the south of us in
massachusetts
1584 was submitted to establish an
improvement grant capital improvement
grant program for the state fairs which
exist in our state
and the state fair association has
approximately 11 state fairs now
currently operating within that
association and within that association
there's definite
rules and criteria for being member i
won't go into that
this bill was
we want to continue
supporting our fares to promote
agriculture in our state which is a key
industry and a key economic driver in
many locations
throughout north south east and west
it's also a rural economic development
factor that we need to look at and
maintain and it's an education factor
and this is why from the education side
of things i got very involved with it
and working with our future farmers of
america and with the 4-h
so
what we're looking at is the are these
fares and during the past several years
i would say the next last 20 years or so
there has been no support for these
fares other than what you can get at the
gate as revenue coming in
or what they pay once they're inside
and and to keep these fares operational
due to the
numerous code changes we've had in terms
of health life and safety in terms of
the amount of energy has to be used in
these with three phase having to be
brought in it's been very very difficult
so
the overall purpose is to try to
establish an improvement grant program
that's under the management of the
department of agriculture
and and marketing uh commissioner jasper
and to have a non-lapsing fund available
in which folks could apply for a grant
to help them with their capital
improvements now there is certain psych
criteria
and conditions that must be met and i'm
not going to go through them you can
read the bill just as well as i can and
i know you're busy so i won't go through
those conditions and criteria
five percent of the grant money
appropriate can be left behind for
administration of the program at
where we got the idea for putting this
forward was from numerous states
throughout this country from washington
uh state vermont utah kansas so it's a
bit of everything in it
back in 1939 in this date through 1987
we had rockingham
and from that we from the para mutual
pools distribution to the fairs from a
portion of the tax gained from these
pools was used in support of the affairs
and in 1979
that generated approximately 275 000
and and for the agricultural affairs of
which 50 000 dollars
was for fair improvements
the fair improvements are going on in
the ferris right now it's very very
costly to as i mentioned to upgrade
these buildings and grounds
and so
the fares are trying to deal with this
through just they have jacked up their
admittance rates to get into the
fairgrounds and it's really at a very
uh low rate in terms about 15 bucks
ahead thereabouts give and take the
various fair weather in rochester
whether you're up in north haverhill
where i hail from where we have the
north haverford prayer
the the affairs generate
and from what i've gotten through the
plymouth state university where they
have done research on this
is that back i'll go back the farthest i
could get was in 2002
visitors exhibitors and operators spent
an estimated for 40.6 million dollars at
or near the fairgrounds during the fairs
including four hundred thousand dollars
in direct purchases from those on the
grounds
so it is as it is a revenue generator it
slipped in 2011 to 37.1 million dollars
of which
those fares back then had an
approximately 907 jobs that they were
there
needed to make their fares operate since
then the number of people that are paid
to do these fares has shrunk
significantly
and in haverhill for example 300
volunteers are used each year to make
that fair grounds work
they're also using the buildings and
their folks here for storage during the
winter months so that there is revenue
coming year round in order to be
qualifying for these grants should be
had to be operational at least three
days in which there is a fair offer of
which there's eight hours per day
and that's that's generally speaking
what you will see not generally that is
what you're seeing for anybody that
would be applying for a grant
from you they're all non-profits
some of the fairgrounds are currently
paying their property tax others are
in their paying that property tax not
looking for an exclusion or an exception
from the town simply because they do not
want to pass that burden on
to the taxpayer
that's that's a mixed bag on amongst our
fares right now they are trying
everything they can however the capital
improvements uh the the budgets which
they have have that built in
however it can't keep up with some of
the code restrictions that we must have
in affairs and i hate to see new
hampshire's fares which are a draw when
i was coming to the north available fair
i just spent a couple couple days out in
new york state out in niagara falls and
as i passed through the rutland area i
stopped at the visitors center in
vermont
and the lady the counter said i see you
have new hampshire plates on your car
i'm going to be over there and pike
tomorrow for the opening of the north
haverhill fair we attract people from
all over new england we we need that
revenue we need to support these fairs
we need to support our education and the
all the economics around these fairs
it's it's a a driver of our economy and
i hate to see it go down down the toilet
thank you very much be glad to take any
questions there's others here that can
give you more specifics than myself
well thank you representative ladd uh
representative romney uh thank you mr
chair thank you uh representative i just
want to make sure so the 250 is
an ask every year
yes and that we put that in there i i
talked with the commissioner you know at
first i was always go for the sky and he
said no no be careful
and and that may be high i don't know
but we need to have some kind of a an
area where we can go and seek that money
in these circumstances help us with the
capital needs you're required if you
receive a grant to put in a a match up
to
15 or higher
uh to supplement what you're asking for
okay thank you you're welcome further
questions
uh representative
aaron thank you mr chair thank you
representative ladd for your testimony
today
um when we had a previous hearing on
this bill
that we recessed
um
represent i believe it was
representative dutsy who
was was asking the question of why
wouldn't we have
local businesses
be paying
towards
uh the upkeep or capital improvements of
these properties if they are
receiving such a benefit of uh increase
of their business because of all the
visitors that come
i hate looking around this doing here
but um
we have the local businesses in the area
that i live in right now that are paying
to be exhibitors there within the
fairgrounds so that's a revenue that
comes in
they're also providing support
throughout the school year not school
yet the annual year to uh support our
fairs through their volunteer services
and providing supplemental uh
uh equipment etc to help do some of
these jobs that's how we put a parking
up there in the haverhill area we did
that in conjunction with our business
community and that was a free service
that they were providing that we're
getting that out of folks like the agway
uh folks right there in haverhill so yes
we're going down that road but the
expenses the costs are are exceeding
what our revenue is thank you i'm glad
you clarified that thank you
further questions
sand none thank you thank you very much
norm
next is
commissioner of agriculture
sean jasper
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i am sean jasper commissioner
of department of agriculture markets and
food and i
am here in support of of the bill
now i'm
the chairman has reminded me that i
should stick with the issue of
of the uh of the fund because the policy
uh has been adopted by the house on a
vote of 236 to 105. so
the house has has spoken very strongly
that they are in support of this
this concept um
i do want to just deviate from that a
little bit
so the history of
state support for our fairs actually
goes back
uh well before the civil war
there have been starts and stops but the
state has had a general policy
over the years of supporting our fairs
recognizing the importance to
to new hampshire and to promoting
agriculture and actually through 4-h and
many of the other youth organizations
getting the youth involved and this is
an opportunity for them to show and to
learn and for obviously kids who do not
come from
um
rural areas to to learn about
agriculture
so i'll i'll stop there of course i'll
be glad to answer questions moving
forward but why a
a non-lapsing fund well these expenses
are not lineal you're not going to have
the same needs every year
as many of you may know tragically
rochester fair which has been struggling
and actually was closed for a year
before reorganization
lost a horse barn just last week to fire
um
so there's a real need there and that is
not going to be something that hopefully
we see every year
we do have the component of matching
we do want to see in
community involvement there there are
going to be times when the needs are
going to far exceed a 250
000 a year appropriation these these
improvements are getting very expensive
uh many of the life safety codes some of
which i find to be ridiculous given the
nature of the structures are still
putting a tremendous burden on the fares
that's something that we as government
are doing to the fairs
um and so i think this is important it
does
continue a a tradition that has existed
albeit has been a lapse now of
of over 40 years but if you look at that
275 000 roughly that that went to the
fairs 43 years ago
um
that that number would be what well over
half a million at this point we're
asking for
a quarter million so i'll i'll end my
testimony there but be glad to answer
any questions
thank you commissioner jasper
representative
schamberg
i went to hilton head also so we're
getting closer to home we're going to
remember my name here thank you mr
chairman
thank you for taking my questions i do
have some follow-ups on this
coming from the state of ohio
originally every county has a fair how
many
fairs are there presently being run in
the state of new hampshire i believe the
number is
11. we have lost
a couple of fares since the state has
stopped
most recently stratum
has stopped they may try to do something
but it's not going to be a full-blown
fare
plymouth actually did not survive the
transition and i think very quickly
after the state stopped supporting
plymouth went away and other as i said
rochester has struggled others have and
unfortunately with affairs much like
agriculture in general very dependent on
the weather
if we could guarantee that every fair
had sunny weather for their their runs i
don't think we'd be
asking for this but um
that's a problem and i do do think that
most every state does
support their fares
recognizing uh the value to the state
follow-up question mr chairman
uh
on page two
line five
it starts 426-b
colon four and it's roman numeral
uh number
i'm sorry it's
lines
seven and eight under that
however the commissioner may make
exceptions to the above conditions and
criteria
uh is there a report that you would or
the agricultural commissioner would send
out
to
[Music]
a committee within
the state legislature
page page two i'm sorry commissioner no
line five and then it goes
seven and eight the line seven and eight
there
the commissioner may make exceptions
all right um
i just like know who does the
commissioner report to when they make
exceptions well i don't think that's in
in the bill and certainly that would be
a reasonable
amendment in my opinion to the bill to
have
the
the commissioner give a give a report of
the expenditures to someone obviously
those expenditures will be out there in
general as part of
the process but i think to have a
specific
report go to a
committee of the legislature would not
be unreasonable in the least bit
and my final question follow-up mr
do you feel that these organizations
maybe should create
a foundation and raise money through
the vehicle the foundation
i don't think they need to have a
foundation they're already able to to
raise money
um but it is very difficult i will say
that the um
cornish
yes the cornish fair
had a very successful
fundraising for a uh
for a livestock pavilion i was at the
dedication
this past summer but they had some very
very generous local tradesmen who
participated in that and it did take a
long time to do that but cornish is one
of the the smaller fares and you look at
some of the the needs and some of the
neglect
that has has gone on
just for for lack of resources
that i think this small amount
uh is something that that the state
hopefully and certainly
indicated by the vote of the legislature
is willing to
to assist because if we lose our fares
we do lose a very important part of
who we are
representative romney
thanks chair
thank you uh commissioner jasper
so
ways and means no problem us looking at
capital improvement grant program fund
establishing that fund that's our and
our belly wick
what's not on our bailiwick is the
appropriation of the 250 000
a year so
now this bill is effective
july 1st so beginning of the second year
my understanding from
speaking to the chair of finance
that she's already has a list of 300
million dollars
of
ass in first committee bills
about 200 plus another 100 million that
they want to set aside for the sununu
center or lawsuits
so i don't know procedurally how we're
going to do this but we passed a bill
with the 250 in it
i don't know if it goes to fiscal
committee to try to get that
appropriated down the road
yeah i think you're well versed in this
uh what's your take on how this will
work to get the actual money in it
well i i think generally
um speaking the money has to be there
for something like this to be
to be funded now
i i was somewhat surprised that it came
here and not
to finance that's my point that's my
point
however this is the beginning of the the
process it's certainly going to go to
the senate
and no doubt
after the policy committee
to
senate finance
where that would probably be more
appropriately
discussed
but um
you know we are we are where we are and
have have the the timing i mean i
certainly you know if it were to go to
um house
finance i i don't know what the the
timing of that is but it would be
somewhat unusual to have they'll go
thank you mr chairman good to see you mr
commissioner
i have a question for you going back to
the funding the sort of leans off of
what representative schomburg said just
a few minutes ago uh in in other
verticals or industries we've seen uh
public and private partnerships uh
happen where endowments were made
in
healthcare in the arts
where larger corporations came in to
help support and fund in a handshake and
a contractual agreement with
with the state or other areas do were
there any conversations uh in the past
with any of our
new hampshire larger businesses to see
if they would help create endowments to
help out with this i i think the
unfortunate part i guess the simple
question is
no
or probably not
but i think the reality is that most of
the larger corporations don't have any
interest in in agriculture agriculture
in new hampshire is a
unfortunately for the most part a a
contracting industry
um we're losing uh equipment dealers
they already are as supportive as they
can be
uh and they're stretched then you know
we have 4h we have ffa we
the few that we have who really care
about agriculture
are constantly being asked for money and
and generally speaking they are very
supportive but when you get into these
big asks there are fewer and fewer
businesses
who we can ask
and that's that's the problem because i
know that all the fair associations are
constantly struggling with this very
question how do we get the funding and
and this is why we're here because it's
simply
not there
thanks sir welcome
thank you
any further questions representing elmi
and we have five more pink cards oh my
we there are two places in
from which on the governor could take
money for a one-time
on
contribution
unfortunately the majority party in this
committee
just voted against doing that for
another thing that
is probably higher on the governor's
priorities
but
on
but on one of them
general category
economic development workforce
development
and the other one
is
on
capital investment
in
on
which is a general category with in
which
people are coming in and asking for
money for a specific capital maintenance
on
ranging from 25 million dollars
allocated so far down to 84 000.
and um
it's spent
almost 50 million now but there is
still money available
that the governor hasn't allocated yet
and
my question on
this side of it
is um
if
on
from arpa
to a non-lapsing fund
on
that would give some
ability for the state to
figure out a way to recover its revenue
position which is
very peculiar right now we have no idea
whether we have a surplus or not we
don't have a surplus in terms of what
immediately this year or is told by
others that we ought to be doing
immediately this year
with the general funds so my question is
i thought i'd made that clear was on
do you see that being
at least a temporary solution that could
i i suppose it could but i will ask you
that i have an ask into arpa for
um
capital
already relative to food sustainability
um we have many food hubs and and co-ops
and i have
working with with folks at
uh unh and in all of these organizations
we put in an ask for money for
processing refrigeration packing
transportation to be able to allow our
small farms to come together and have an
impact because right now in order to get
into a market basket or demoulas or
shaw's you need to have the the quantity
of products
and the ability to
um
supply that throughout the year so
that's where my focus has been um
in this this particular case um
you know currently
on the books
there is already
a funding of the fairs
but it's not been appropriated so my
feeling is that if the legislature
gets to the point where they feel we
can't sustain this program
they'll do exactly
what's been done in the past and not
appropriate anything in this statute
notwithstanding
we'll have have a change as many do i
think it's it's time to look to the long
term
and not just the short term and so my
ask is for a long term
solution to a long-term product
problem unlike my other ask which i
think actually gets us off the ground
provides what we need to establish that
and then that in and of itself can be
self-sustaining this is never something
that will be self-sustaining
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
commissioner for taking my question i i
guess my question
comes around the idea of the fact that
what we're really it sounds like what
we're really asking is a reinvestment
back in that the state benefits through
tourism dollars through rooms and meals
taxes that are collected
i don't know how much you guys like
funnel cake but i spent plenty of my
fair share of money on funnel cake um
even though it doesn't show i suppose um
but anyway what we're really asking
about is a reinvestment into these
industries that are that are already
providing tourism dollars into our state
and and rooms and meals dollars into our
state and to finally support them as
part of the state program as they're
sending money to the state is that what
we're looking to
i think you said that much better than i
did thank you
any further questions if not thank you
commissioner jasper thank you
next is robert johnson ii
representing the new hampshire farm
bureau
in support of the bill and you said you
thank you thank you mr chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is rob johnson representing the new
hampshire farm bureau as the
federation's policy director
farm bureau is a federation consisting
of the 10 new hampshire county farm
bureau organizations with with about
1800 family memberships and another 1
000 supporting and other types of
memberships and and we are in support of
of the bill
we
want to first quickly say that we we do
we support the bill because we support
the the new hampshire affairs in what
they provide the state
the affordable family entertainment
that provides a number of educational
opportunities to the public such as
where the food comes from exposure to a
number of agricultural and forestry
types of uh
exhibits rule ways that type of thing
but i think most importantly
what the fears do
is that they showcase
the work of our youth
which is very important it's very
important to to our youngsters to have
that exposure and it's something the
fares do maybe better than anything
again specifically to the bill is what
we support and and representative lane
can just basically just said it i guess
is that it provides uh
some funds a little part there that the
fares can leverage
for the purposes as as we've heard uh to
make uh capital improvements
uh uh deal with the challenges of many
of them now operate basically on
volunteer staffs that are
more challenging to up to to obtain all
the time
in the interest of time mr cha i'll
leave it at that but just
with your permission i have a handout uh
business new hampshire magazine about
five years ago wrote a very pretty short
piece and it does a good job i think of
speaking to the challenges that we've
mentioned here and i'll leave it at that
and thank you for the opportunity well
thank you for your testimony you take
questions
yes
the next is
a bob allen new hampshire fair
association
i did not come here with a
prepared speech but i did want to speak
to the committee i am currently the
president of the new hampshire fair
association
which makes up
the 11 fairs that we've talked about
plus one festival i believe
and i do know for a fact that each of
the fairs that are able to qualify
for these funds
certainly have needs and uses for them
and not all of them are here today
i'm very familiar with cheshire
cornish and i am a director and
treasurer of huffington so i'm familiar
with that fair
very well as
very well as well
i have talked with some of the people at
the fairs that are not represented today
and they are certainly supportive of
this bill
although they couldn't all be here to
speak
so
in that regard i'm not going to speak
for those fairs because i don't know
their individual
issues and problems but i can speak to
the
issues at cheshire a little bit they are
in dire need of some electrical upgrades
they are in dire need of some bathroom
facilities
and probably other projects but those
are two that i talked with gary davis
who is the president
about just recently this week
at hopkinton
a few years ago we did a very extensive
electrical upgrade to the grounds
it was somewhere in the vicinity of a
half a million dollars
we're still paying off that loan as we
speak today
but it was necessary to do in order to
create safety through the electrical
grid at hopkinton
we have
a project going right now that involves
changing the lighting to led lights
to help with the energy costs at the
hopkinton fair
and we do have a major issue with our
bleachers i'll call them bleachers some
people call them grandstands but they're
really bleachers
in meeting the codes and it's probably
probably the only way that we're going
to
meet those codes is to
remove them
and build new or do extensive
renovations to the existing bleachers
i've had a quote to replace the
bleachers
entirely
it's over a million dollars that's
something that we can't afford and we
can't
you know even attempt to do so we will
downsize
we will
modify when and if necessary
in order to meet the codes and hopefully
we'll be able to continue to
have a show
large show in front of a
that said i don't have anything prepared
but i would take any questions that you
might have and turn it over to someone
else
representative romney
thank you mr chairman southward i'm not
selfish
hamburg
thank you thank you for testimony over
here
over here yep
so
yeah i'm from stratham so i understand
what's going on in stratham um
it's a tough it's a tough it gets
tougher and tougher every year for fares
i understand
and
some years it's all about the weather
right it's all about the weather if it's
if it's rainy couple days you lose money
if it's too hot
you lose money if it's a little better
than that you actually can
make a few bucks and obviously that
money gets reinvested into the fares
uh i just want you to speak to that real
quick i mean
the efforts that are made i mean
these aren't big profit making fares
correct i mean they make some a good
year
they make some money they'll and there's
boards i know that run these fairs that
will make judgments as to where to put
the money
and making improvements because
obviously improvements do happen without
it but
it just seems the last bunch of years
it's been well first we didn't have a
fair couple years because the covert
and we decided not to reopen as a full
fare we're not going to have the kearney
rides this coming year we're going to
have we want we want to preserve it for
the 4-h
folks still have all those all those
things for the 4-h kids and all that but
anyway but in terms of
other sources of money namely the the
fares making money
to then put back into capital
investments you can you speak to that
uh yeah i can uh and to your points uh
the weather
a few years ago at hopkinton
the weather forecast i believe it was
for sunday was supposed to be in the 90s
with high humidity
on saturday of that day the crowds were
enormous because they knew they were not
going to be able to come on sundays so
you've got a beautiful day it's hot and
it's humid but people don't come the
flip side of that is
the weather forecasters can be our
biggest enemies when they forecast rain
and it doesn't occur people don't plan
on coming so they don't come
but in in terms of making money or
reinvesting that money
uh it's very difficult
to spend all the money that you may make
in any one year
even though you know you have a capital
project that needs to be done you have a
barn roof that needs to be repaired
whatever the case might be
you're always
looking at the coming year and we start
this the month after our fair ends
all right we need to be sure we can open
the grounds next year so what can we do
in the meantime between now and next
year
to
to support the infrastructure that we
already have and that's a difficult call
to make because you never know what the
weather's going to be come 2023 for
example
so
it's
it's something that you have to do but
it's something that you have to be very
cautious in doing as well because if you
spend all of the funds that you make
this year
there may not be enough funds to to
support the fair in the
coming year in the following year
because there are certain fixed expenses
which have been talked about real estate
taxes insurance
payroll and things like that you have to
be prepared to cover that
thank you thank you
representative schamberg followed by
representative aaron thank you mr
chairman
over here sir thank you uh
looking on your third page in i see that
you've listed the fair season 2017.
my question is
is there a town in each of the counties
of new hampshire that holds a fair to
your knowledge do you know
i
i don't know that i know that there is
sandwich that's fair north available
fair right cornish fair but those are
fine all right and follow sir
is there a state fair
well the hopkinton state fair
however
people have said and thought that we
received monies from the state that's
not true it's simply a name that we
you might say pirated once the plymouth
state fair folded up
we applied for that immediately
the directors at the time i wasn't on
the board but the directors at the time
immediately applied for that designation
but there is no money that goes with it
from the state
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you to for
coming today to testify on this bill in
this committee
my question to you is actually i'm
interested to hear your thoughts on
how
any of these fairs
may struggle
with the expenses to incorporate
ada accessibility
on the fairgrounds
and the costs associated with doing that
well again i i can't speak for every
fair and and what they're doing but i
know
again at the hopkinton fair
uh we have made all of our buildings uh
handicapped accessible as much as we can
we have provided in some of the enclosed
buildings
special
seating for the
handicapped impaired wheelchair areas as
well as lower seating on the bleachers
for
people that are mobile but can't climb a
set of bleachers or stairs or whatever
so i know at our fair we are
i think we are 100
compliant with with people being able to
access all of the buildings
uh there and i'm sure the other fairs
are are doing similar things
but i can't speak to them directly
further questions
the neck thank you very much okay
next is
good morning thank you
you would all probably know us better as
rochester fair
last week we lost a 40-stall barn to
fire
it was uninsured
and
we are going to have to do some
rebuilding
however
when you rebuild something you have to
and that's going to involve
in our town putting a sprinkler system
in
which is going to cost more
than the barn will itself
these are challenges
that the fares face
you know um
the fairs have
only a couple real sources of revenue
your admission is usually your number
one
your carnival is your second
you have to take that money and that's
what funds things like exhibitions
the crafts the animals all of those are
expenses to the fair
we have very little income
that is reaching out to pay
all of the outgo of maintaining old
buildings
we have a large old victorian style
exhibition building
and it's a constant work
in progress to maintain
and to bring up to codes
for many years the fairs
didn't
necessarily
have to
bring stuff up to code that was kind of
ignored
and now there's been a real push for
handicap accessibility electrical work
we've all we've all faced that
many parts of the country
you hear the talk of county fair or
state fair
that usually designates a fair that gets
financial support from the county or the
state
in new hampshire the fairs are
self-supporting
and it's
just something that you're not able to
sustain anymore
most of the
help and sponsorship of the fairs
came from
the agricultural industries
because we were agricultural fares
i'm a dairy farmer in the state of new
hampshire
when i started in 1974 there were 650
dairy farms shipping milk less than 100
today
that pool of people who are going to
sponsor the fares has gotten smaller and
smaller
and we reach out to whoever we have
but there's just so many dollars
and with agriculture exiting
the northeast as rapidly as it is
we no longer have the pool of people to
go after for sponsorship
i am old enough to remember
when the fairs had a stipend fund and it
was very helpful
um
you know other states do
maine and vermont have have a program
similar and it's been very beneficial
so i hope you i hope you folks can
support that
thank you thank you for testimony
representative browner romney has it
chad thanks for your testimony
so does rochester fair still have perry
mutual and do you know of any of the
other fairs that have prairie mutual
racing as part of their festival no
we ended uh paramutual in 2007 after
it's been a while losing years okay
we were only we were one of only three
fairs in the state of new hampshire that
ever had paramutual
and that was plymouth and at one time
there was a fair in pittsfield that had
paramutual okay thank you so that's not
a revenue stream at all okay thank you
it hadn't been for many many years okay
just money make sure thank you
representative schamberg
thank you mr chairman thank you for
if the state were to go ahead with this
appropriation
you mentioned that your barn was
uninsured
will the county will these
fairgrounds have to have insurance i
don't know if the other ones have
insurance on their property
like your buildings
i can speak to the insurance in
rochester
all of our
newer buildings are insured some of the
older barns they deemed
uninsurable because they're hard to
secure
we do shut the electricity off in the
winter but thank you um most of our
newer buildings are insured
further questions
thank you
the next we have neil kirk from the
hey mr couric
representative major it's good to see
you
and
good afternoon to you and to members of
the committee for the record i'm neil
kirk i live in the town of where but i'm
here representing granite state
taxpayers some of you may know that i
was a state representative for many
years
granite state taxpayers is new
hampshire's oldest statewide taxpayer
advocacy group
it was founded in 1990 by the
late governor mel thompson and the late
granite state taxpayers opposes this
bill for four reasons
first it's special interest legislation
taxpayers are being asked to subsidize a
specific set of businesses
although
largely non-profit and serving a very
important agricultural industry in our
state these fares
do in fact have a source of income and
should be self-supporting
those fares that are profitable such as
deerfield
can finance their capital improvements
through bank loans they needn't rely on
taxpayers
those fares that are not profitable
should raise their admission and other
sources of income
or sad to say
cease operations
number two a state subsidy for a dying
business even those that may enjoy
and help an industry that's important to
our state is not in the public interest
unless the proponents can demonstrate
that the capital improvements will
generate an increase in state tax
revenues
over their useful life
exceeding the cost to the state of the
project
three the grant program will do nothing
to deal with the fundamental problem
facing agricultural fares their
diminishing appeal to the younger
generation and the challenge of keeping
fares relevant amidst trends of
declining involvement in agriculture
there are many studies to this effect
fourth
beyond all of those basic points there
are some practical and constitutional
the bill delegates rulemaking to the
commissioner
but under our constitution in the
federal constitution
where we have
separation of powers the three branches
of government
the legislative branch cannot delegate
legislative authority to the executive
house bill 1584 violates this precept in
two provisions
first with respect to the basic grant
that's the one for buildings
the criteria are laid out in section 426
b 5 2
but not their weights
so for example
is having high gate receipts gate
receipts being one of the criteria that
the commissioners to consider a positive
or a negative
that depends upon whether the
commissioner not the legislature
decides that the grant program is to be
income tested
that's a legislative decision
you folks need to decide that you can't
leave it the way it is in the bill
and then the commissioner is given
the exception power that's on page two
line seven and eight it was discussed
before
without any criteria
so the commissioner in effect is being
granted the power that the legislator
legislature has and must use to
legislate that can't stand without
some sort of criteria indicating
exceptions for what based on what
criteria
secondly
there's a second part of this uh grant
program called the health improvements
part of the program
that's
426 b
comma i
two that would be page two lines
um
ah yes thank you page three
yes page three lines four through six
subject to the availability of funds the
department may provide grant funds on a
competitive basis to support capital
projects that make health and safety
improvements to agricultural fares etc
there are absolutely no criteria
if the bill is to go forward and granite
state taxpayers does not wish it to go
forward
somebody needs to figure out what the
criteria are and put them into the bill
otherwise i think you've delegated
legislative authority unconstitutionally
to the executive branch
for these reasons mr chairman
granite state taxpayers asks that you
either
itl the bill or refer it for interim
study
that concludes my testimony mr chairman
i'd be pleased to answer any questions
mr kirk could you um email
or
give a copy of your testimony to our
any questions representative romney yeah
i i
rep representative kirk um a former
workforce
um
oh you're always you're the honorable it
never goes away
so that first read the first on the
constitutional thing you mentioned can
you tell us again page and i missed that
one page and uh
and
um
426 b52
4 26
2. that starts on
and specifically
line 31 this merit rating shall take
into account such factors as and there's
a whole list of things there
including
so with what you've done is to say uh
commissioner jasper you have to consider
all of these things
but the bill doesn't say what waits to
give and what the meaning is and the
commissioner can make this program
an income-tested program or open to
everybody regardless of the
profitability of the fair
there are just no criteria for him to
make a decision
and therefore um
that's unconstitutional you you folks as
legislators have to say
what it is you you can't give the
executive branch um regulation writing
authority and create the program
on its own
you've you've got to be more specific
and set the criteria what is the program
to be can the deerfield fair get money
even if it's profitable or do you want
to reserve the money just affairs that
are losing money and that are might go
out of existence
whatever whatever the decision is it's a
legislative decision and not an
executive branch decision the way the
bill is set up
the decision is left to the executive
branch
thank you honorable kirk for taking my
question and thank you mr chair i guess
my question is around the discussion
around 541a and rulemaking authority
that's giving to agencies and and not
just in this particular case but i guess
in general to understand your philosophy
and what you're thinking are you saying
that whenever we give
agencies rulemaking authorities say with
the efa programs that that's
unconstitutional and we have to be more
detailed the more specific and
everything we send to the to through the
house
thank you for the question
representative lang
i think the answer is yes
the legislature frequently in my
experience has set up programs and
basically left it to the executive
branch to really decide what the program
is we we the legislature decides you
know there's a problem and it'll cost
250 000 to fix it but we'll let the
department of health and human services
figure out the rules as to how to make
that money fix the problem
i think that is a failure on the part of
the legislature and if it were
challenged in court and it rarely is
admittedly but if it were challenged in
court those rules would fail for the
legislature's failure to create the
criteria for the program that enabled
the rules to implement it
and it's always debatable as to how far
you have to go to do that
but i think this is pretty clear that
while you've established criteria the
program could go in so many different
directions based on the administrative
discretion that the legislature if this
bill were to become law has failed to go
far enough to meet its constitutional
responsibility to delegate authority to
the executive branch
thank you one follow-up question
follow-up
so you don't think that the job car
process
in using the administration reviewing
and approving administrative rules as a
legislative body both senate and house
doesn't meet that criteria
as i understand djelkar its purpose is
to make sure that the intent of the
legislature
is implemented by the rules
but where ion gel car were you on jail
car i think you would have a very
difficult time of saying what the
legislat whether the rules met that
criteria because the legislature hasn't
set it out now gelcar could make its own
decision and in effect become a mini
legislature but my understanding is that
wasn't the
wasn't the basis for granting gelcar the
review authority it has
thank you and i do serve on gelcar
and i'm sure you're aware of some of the
issues
any further questions
not thank you uh
honorable
you know kirk
thank you mr chairman it's a pleasure to
be here and to see you folks someone
said before that this bill probably
should have gone to finance
and
that probably is the case but right it's
yeah okay the last pink card
is from david lackey
uh from north
haverhill fair
well thanks for having us here today and
it's getting late so we're trying not to
keep moving on here um
i support this bill uh north havel fair
um we same as everybody else we struggle
with all the new rules and regulations
probably for the last 10 12 years
printing everything we've had to spend
has been into electrical upgrades that
are required
and if you don't know electrical is huge
dollars and you really don't get much
back
we're probably better than some
fairgrounds as we moved to our location
in 1980 and built some new buildings but
as time goes on they're all in buildings
and needing
repairs upgrades
same as hopping on our bleachers are not
in good shape
and every year when we get done the fare
we're okay we did okay we broke even we
might have made a little money
um i think we're like a lot of other
fears our off-season rentals
is huge to us with we have a lot of
wedding receptions in the building
storage is is big but it still does not
give us enough money
to do our capital improvements that we
need to do
somebody made the comment
why don't you guys do more
fundraising type stuff on your own
i'm here to say we're the fair that has
the 300 volunteers
and with what we do
it just doesn't work to ask our people
to do any more for free
i'm i'm probably old enough i've only
heard the stories about what used to
come when rockingham park was going and
it was a huge asset to the fares and uh
you know whatever we could get is going
to be a huge asset now no matter how big
or how small it is it just
it's a struggle
i our ferris by-laws are
to support the 4-h
luckily up in grafton county we still
have a large 4-h
group we have the kids come in
and that's what drives me is to see
these kids in there doing their projects
what the adults get out of it for
happiness is great but the kids is what
drives drives me
so
any support would be appreciated and
i'll take any questions
thank you for your testimony represent
aaron
oh there you go sorry
thank you mr chair thank you for your uh
testimony today
i'm interested to know um
what percentage of your
income annually is from your
off season rentals and 4-h participation
and
i guess i really i don't have that info
to answer um
no i know i know it's a decent number
um
i know our storage alone is like thirty
to forty thousand dollars
so as a percentage though what you don't
know
okay thank you i'm the president not the
treasurer okay
representative romney uh this is a
curiosity question now you mentioned you
mentioned rockingham park and in its
heyday it really did it was
generated a lot of money for the state
so
was there an earmark when in those days
that some of that money went from
rockingham to the affairs or did you
mention if you wrenching that i wasn't
sure what you meant i believe i'm in the
impression back in the day one quarter
of one percent of their income or their
take
went to the fairs okay so that's the
source of yes
and the commissioner is putting a thumbs
up so you got it right thank you
i just i was just at that time that was
big money yeah i'm sure rocky and
parkland and his day generated a lot of
revenue so thank you representative
tucker
so i'm thinking what would be comparable
to
that kind of arrangement were we working
with sports betting
or casinos or
in other words they had this minute
amount of money from
a betting situation is that correct yes
that supported the fares
so
we're a big group here what is
comparable now in the state
to that that we could tag in as an
arrangement
uh that i don't know i do know what i
think we were setting on was if the
state and new hampshire have had ever
approved the casino
that's where we were going to go
to do the same thing to get a percentage
of their take
what's out there now i
i really don't know
so there are probably people on this
go ahead and answer the question and
then yeah i mean the closest thing would
be trying to somehow tap into charitable
gaming
in a way that
allows the
affairs to participate in some fashion
it's the the closest i could see how
about the sports spreading online sport
again that would be a different bill i
mean
it's a comparability in today's world
yeah oh yeah i mean it used to be funded
by rockingham park i mean it was racing
so that's why charitable gaming with
historic racing coming i know a lot of
you didn't like that but
um
with historic racing coming that would
even be closer to it because it's
equivalent to what it used to be
so i'm very keen as a member someone
from colus county
who has enjoyed the lancaster fair
most of my life
and now uh from time to time take
photographs for a magazine of a
newspaper called country folks
uh of fairs so i've been
around
to take photographs of fares there's
just no question in my mind that
the importance of our affairs to youth
is very very high it's the highlight of
their year of raising animals those who
are into that
and then those who do the more crafts
and things i'm not quite as interested
in
it's a it's a target of being prepared
for something
in lancaster at the lancaster fair
there's a close relationship between the
regional high school
and its uh cte program
and they
operate and run
exhibits
where they deal with the public with
younger children they teach them about
agriculture
there's a lot of maple sugaring and they
have a sugaring program at the cte
program
at white men's
regional high school
so there's a close relationship between
education from the youngest
in 4-h the little clover buds or
whatever
up to high school so i'm keen to find a
revenue source but i on the other hand
realize that representative kirk
does know a lot about how things work
and we need to find something else
perhaps than the arrangement that's in
this bill
um i think it's a very worthwhile aim
but we need to find something that
actually will work and that's what you
believe right what that's what you
believe
and and will produce the kind of money
because we're talking about
a lot of money
and this is just a little bit that we're
talking about but when you talk about
electrical
uh work at fairgrounds it's a major
problem first on the
on the codes and then
on
energy saving
so it's just a huge problem i can see
that
and
find solutions
that are
perhaps more realistic than what has
okay um i think the commissioner
jasper wanted to say something
with me
i think there's another question for you
but i i just wanted to to make it clear
that what happened when the paramutual
went to support the fairs it wasn't
because everybody thought or even
rockingham park thought this was the
right thing to do it was actually a
hostage situation
so rockingham park which wished to
expand to night racing they needed
legislative approval to do that it came
down to a situation
where
um one senator was the person who
in 24-24 it seems like there must have
been somebody else involved i guess
that's not the important part it's the
important part is
that he said the only way i'm going to
allow this to happen
is if there is support for the fairs
and since rockingham park was there on
the table
he grabbed that quarter of a percent so
it really
that's how that came about it didn't
have anything
to do with oh everybody thinks this is
the way to fund the fairs it just was
that convenient hostage to take and so
questions for mr
blacky
represent schamberg
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking this
would you believe
that i think it would behoove this
committee to move this to interim study
for this bill
to make it work because our future
depends upon
the farmers and the people that grow and
produce our food would you believe that
yep
i like your short answer
any further questions
thank you for your time thank you i'm
right if anybody else have anything
that they want to say for or against
house bill 1584
if not then i'm closing the public
hearing on house bill 1584. thank you
for
representative
so uh for everybody mr chair
the way i look at the calendar we have
two weeks left
next week we have three session days
but the big bill before us is the
marijuana bill the cannabis bill
and if if we don't
we i guess the question is are we
planning on a monday or a friday to do
something on the marijuana bill
or we're going to leave it all to the
last week because of the calendar
we have to have this thing voted out
that last week
and i think it's going to take more than
one day to my time schedule to figure
out the rest of the calendar
and work around the
sessions
is within the next hour i've got to make
yes
so i i will say there's a group of uh
legislators that are trying to work out
what we can fix in the in that um
marijuana bill to make it work
um and i'm happy to take anybody who
wants to come and join us i know a
couple of us are going to lunch today to
have a discussion about it and i also
have already asked the governor for an
appointment to chat with him about any
proposed amendments we have to see how
that's going to work with his office to
make sure that we don't uh poison pill
the bill um if he's in favor in favor of
it so um i'd ask for a little bit of
time so we can work together we've had a
couple industry experts we've had
conversations with um but and and we'd
like to see a bill that we could move
forward with i just had a conversation
with finance about their asks and all
the asks in the bill
so just if i could have some time to try
to put together a laundry list of
changes to the bill that that might make
it more palatable to people to be able
to go through it
thank you i think
we've got a big problem with this in
that
on the sponsor's view of how much
revenue there is
is extremely different from
anything that we've been given from
anywhere else
and that they've put policy in there
that spends all that revenue that he
thinks is coming in
and we're not supposed to deal with
policy
on
we're trying to get some other ways of
figuring out
the revenue
to have a few more triangulations there
but it looks like it's around
40 to 50 million at the most and with
the edibles cut out of it less
so
again i i think that was if you talk
about the net revenue to the state yes
uh that was the number we were working
basing our our amendments and our
conversations around was i think i don't
remember be honest with who presented
this the sheet to us that had that
number was 49 million based on uh
revenue to the state is what they were
estimating and i'm using that as kind of
a basis to
establish policy around that was the
liquor commission yeah that's what i
thought it was so i'm using the liquor
commission's number not anybody else's
number because i feel that it included
edibles
it included portion of edibles yes
well a very small portion
so anyway i just asked for some time to
you know don't schedule this for monday
you know give us some time to to meet
and try to develop an amendment and i'm
happy to work with anybody from either
either side of the aisle to try to get
you know something that a majority of
the committee can support
but can
can the chair think about
this
conundrum we've got of not supposed to
that's going to be tough
thank you
well
i i get well i guess you could say that
i guess changing the policy would be
making edibles in the build completely
or we could say it's a revenue thing
because we're adding more revenue by
doing so
so i don't know that's it i will skirt
that line as close as i can i promise mr
vice chairman
because the revenue
is going to be changed dramatically if
you can do
the animals
again not the edibles as as
bill says now because that's just the
condition
again i i understand mr chair we're
going to try and not change
a significant portion of the policy
there is some that will be some minor
change but again it's around revenue
that we're having the conversation and
the changes in policy so i'm not sure
that'll change the underlying
legalization aspect of the bill it
doesn't say anything about the regular
edibles
you could
there is a segment about
edibles in the bill i can't even say the
word i don't even use this stuff but um
again uh
there is some language in the bill
already about edibles and allowing
edibles in the retail locations for the
state and
it's just about how we deal with some of
that and what that looks like so again
it's already in the bill um we're just
trying to skirt and clean up some
regular animals right and again one of
the like one of the big we're taking
some of the easy swings at stuff like
one of the conversation points was
around banking right it was clear that
the banking language just seemed like to
everybody was unworkable right so that
was like one of the first amendments i
wrote down strike all the banking
language right so that's a simple change
that that you know creating a state bank
isn't reasonable we heard that banking
is available these agencies so it's not
needed in the bill clean language that
would help again bring some people into
the mix and into the fold that might
have objected to the bill for that
reason um there was a conversation
around the
the
the funding and how the funding is split
up and cleaning up that language to make
it again a little more palatable to
people because as i read that bill i had
to go to daryl representative abbas
three times to try to understand what he
was trying to do because of the way that
bill was worded and we were trying to
clean up some of that language as well
um and then it was the we had the simple
error that was market consultants versus
investigators that was a mistake in the
bill i have a language to clean that
portion of the amendment to clean that
up um but and again we're we're meeting
the ideas around the biggest
conversation point is around cultivation
and whether or not we'll allow the atc
cultivators to be able to sell to the
state and what that implications that
are because under the current
bill
under the current law the cultivators
can't sell to the state and so we'd have
to play with that language to allow
those atc cultivators to be able to sell
to the state to create a market that's
already readily available for the state
to kick off from day one
so those are just some of the ideas that
are floating around trying to deal with
okay we have to report the bill out on
the 24th
today is the ninth
the 24th is two weeks from tomorrow
next week
is blown apart
so we have
friday the 18th
and then
and possibly
thursday
so
so mr j if you give me until wednesday
of
next week i'll give you some dates that
might work and we'll have amendments we
can do a work session if you want
but i think we should still have a work
session on the 18th whether you're right
now yeah
we're going to have a meeting
okay
i'll have something ready by then to
have a discussion but i need to
schedule something on
by the 16th
at 2 o'clock for the following
if i don't schedule it so i'd put a
placeholder in pick a date pick a time
we'll show up and if it's not needed
we'll if we finish it all on the 18th we
can just cancel it i don't think we're
going to finish it all in the 18th but
that would be great and i suggest i i
suggest i suppose i've spoken to the
governor about this twice
and he's adamant
he doesn't want edibles in the bill
now he does not he doesn't want edible
stuff that's why it's such a convoluted
bill the way they wrote it
so
in terms of the intervals so you talk to
the governor if he says he's changed his
mind
if you want to save a lot of work but
he's assuming there's no that there's no
edibles in the bill
again that's my reason for meeting with
do you want to create a subcommittee and
just we can work through that or do you
but we are having a session on tuesday
because i haven't heard that oh yeah i
mean i've i've been told second hand but
no no it's in the calendar it's in the
calendar wednesday wednesday thursday
that came out a week or so ago
yeah that's kind of screws us up i think
i read a week to last week's morning
susan
it says additionally please hold 2z
marks 15
like 16
and the 17.
okay and the 31st
that really makes it impossible to do
second committee bills i don't know yet
does it have time so
we have no time to work
all right i got to do a blur okay we're
through
mr chairman
yes i really do think that subcommittee
ought to be an official subcommittee i
think on this topic
transparency is very important i don't
think it will change anything that
happens but i really think it should be
an official subcommittee of ways and
means
who are the members
and whoever they want
because the problem is we can't get it
you